exactly I I write quickly uh three and a  half days three and a half days but  here's a caveat I'd say 90 was terrible  I believe in getting something done no  matter how flawed just to get to the  Finish Line just to get it out just to  get it out because I find the  procrastination and uh diversion is  something that writers Revel in oh I  hope that phone rings you know what I  mean I hope someone invites you to the  beach because or let me see what would I  rather do play golf or sit at this desk  continually reminding myself of how  stupid I am because I can't come up with  an idea so you know this is there's a I  I feel for right yeah a lot of writer  thanks a lot but it ain't about how hard  you hit it's about how hard you can get  hit and keep moving forward how much you  can take and keep moving forward